[Applause]
oh
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
are there any complex interests not
here she is
[Applause]
against it
on our local social media about
someone had asked where the speed limit
or the speed indicator signs went
which i've informed them that that we've
got like three sets is that right
yeah we've got three sets that get moved
around the district and the ones that
were in south brook
have been moved to a hoka from those
other ones and so there's just some
discussion about that
and um also that camera that i asked you
about
um it has gotten noticed and they wanted
to know if it was official or not which
i
informed them that it wasn't and
also that
whilst it had the desired effect
whosoever it is or whatever it is
it has moved a problem elsewhere and so
i've just asked that person to
um either come and see us today which i
don't see them here so
or um maybe talk about that later and
see if there's anything that we can do
but i as as you know we're all aware
there's
limited things that that we as a council
can do but but
there are some things depending on where
it is and what's happening so
um yes there is
a transference of void racer activity
from one place to another at the moment
somewhere but i haven't been told what
street yet how are you finding it um
sarah the five favorite sections um
[Applause]
i went through the end i'm right here
because we're
missing the new fresh marks and then
they don't want my cues as well
yeah so just to be aware that we have
some
issues in the area with boy racers
and questions being asked about the
camera but not entirely negative because
as i said i think it's having its
desired effect of
making people wonder if that's a good
place to do stupid things so
um i think that's it sorry
[Applause]
okay thank you for having sam talk to
you about the bike stands and
also our seat um both of these
uh projects which i guess you'd say has
kind of come
from the borders potential things to
look into
i'm going to take the report as read
you'll see that in terms of the bike
stands we did
have a meeting um where myself and ian
from the roading team met
with shirley thomas and we need to look
at potential options and that
leads to the creation of the plan which
is at the back of your report
and leads to this report being written
to outline
how that could be achieved using the
two thousand dollars that the board had
already allocated towards
by stands and a further
allocational budget from the minor
improvements
and to cover cycling budget to get them
there
in terms of the seat that was a number
one
potential project raised by board
members which we've looked into
and we've spoken to the businesses
or so two businesses where it was
proposed outside of both of them were
quite keen
and with the idea both of them felt they
would be quite well used not only by
people walking on the street
but by their patrons or
there's one of them put into the
husbands or the patrons
and then but that would
require the um a bit of allocation of
budget towards that from your general
landscaping
budget which you do have enough of that
or shifting wish to
happy to answer any questions
[Applause]
have you approached them and shared and
heard of right
so i approached the men's shed and
talked about that with
the uh i can't remember
the chairperson i think it was
that they were as i put it in the report
they were very keen to get involved
um but they wanted a bit of time to
talk through with exactly what the
design could be
how much it's going to cost so we
haven't got a price from them yet and
that's why
in the report i suggested that the board
could allocate
what a normal seat would be worth and
then
we can work with the men's shed to find
what they could do and then hopefully
find a lot of very often they could
get a significantly lower than what we
would normally have from a supplier
um and then any savings from that would
go
back into the into the cafe for
and your next opportunity if that makes
sense
thank you sure
thank you um we did discuss that this
scenes be similar to the ones that set
the town hall in the thing
what what would the price be if they
were the double ones that
are there rather than the single
oh so you joan and i have spoken to ian
who priced them up and
he's confirmed to us that they are the
same same type as what's outside so they
would be in keeping with that
um thomas do you want the cup all the
stains
this year or not do you want
just to try them out and very seriously
yes
you know having the nine um there would
really be an
over cool kill at this stage and perhaps
we can do it in
stages rather than all at once
you got a comment thomas
probably a follow-up question for that
is that uh
are we actually getting the stands keep
because we are buying uh
getting a bulk deal rather than a just a
price for a single one um
probably the other thing to think about
and then the cost of actually getting
them there as part of that
and the more stands we put in the more
cost-effective yes
i think also the number of stands my
understanding is that's been
um loosely agreed knowing
the demand that there is up there so you
know
outside the likes of the bakery is quite
high demand
just as a teaser to see
how the reason felt about that so
my question to you then is that as
you've said
that it will be cost saving for us if we
do
the whole 1 day
it would be slightly cheaper than doing
it in two stages
but the decision at the end of the day
[Applause]
that's one more question financially
with the
can i just ask about the location i
understand that someone went to see
one of the businesses and it says we're
going to put it in the
basically in the garden and they have
suggested that that be relocated to
where the yellow
lines are
[Music]
all six of the businesses where these
are proposed
my understanding is five of those we're
very happy with where
our proposed to go there was one that
wanted a small change
um and ian has assessed that from a
perspective that's still appropriate
i understand it's not a big
now as well yes
because just with the recommendation
there's no
recommendation about option two
so i think the board needs as well
i'll take that as a question um the
reason option um that option one is it
isn't the
um like i said is that
as staff when we looked at it there's
not
huge benefits between option one and two
but option one was certainly the
preferred option intent
in terms of the owner of the building of
the pharmacy
and jazz so he came back and said as
as the owners we would prefer it to be
an optional one
and so we felt well if there's not a
great
difference and which one's better over
the other then
it's and one thing the owner is saying
they prefer this and that would be the
one we would recommend
but that's up to the board to discuss
with regard to those options i would
think that option one
from
in my view would probably be the better
option just because if you've got
people on mobility scooters um due to
the angle that that door is on it can be
quite difficult if they're coming in
from the right side for them to turn
around and swing wide enough to actually
get into the door to the pharmacy
so perhaps option one might be the more
accessible
place to put it although you know it
might have been some people's ocd not to
be perfectly
centered in the middle of the building
it's probably better to have it kind of
i'm assuming that an option of having it
under the
radar is because it's not council land
exactly
yes so we would look to be putting it in
council land
otherwise it gets a bit tricky in terms
of ownership
talking of ocd but um would it be an
option to actually center it between the
in that sort of bay of the building i
don't know what you call it but
between that um sort of pillow thing and
the rock wall at the end would have been
optional
it said that cindy would be we can
center it up the reason we're kind of
pulled it
i guess the insane colors around that
accessibility
side of things that leaves a wider gap
at the end
of the century too narrow against so
it just does help with that
[Applause]
um she sort of said people do come when
they come out of the street they kind of
come in the
earliest opportunity to get under the
meringue if it's raining so
it doesn't and she didn't seem too
concerned with it blocking
um access or anything like that so
that's why it's in there
[Applause]
okay
i'll remove the recommendation that um
from a through to h with
the option one thing and the attachment
is
[Applause]
any further discussion
um
um we've gone through this pretty pretty
thoroughly
um the oxford community members and
myself and and as long as we've got the
the uh okay smartness from that from the
building owner
the people that are renting the place
then i just feel like this
we can go ahead and do it it's going to
be an airset
so
would be like i'm pleased with my
involvement stance i think it's uh it's
great to see
landlord and the business owners who are
supportive it's fantastic
be racist at opec i think you know get
group quite
quite happy with it as well being put in
um i think it's a good news story
too that we need to get some media
[Applause]
coverage
[Music]
between what you found um location-wise
and the staff has a really thoughtfully
um set up proposition and i like the
fact that we have
caught away the scale by doing the
nine all at once and the very thoughtful
placement
of the um bench my hands off to you i
think that would be a great thing for
officer and i'm happy to support it
thanks
[Music]
this is something that both myself and
shirley probably had a lot of
communication with residents over the
last six years
um to be honest it's probably overdue
because at the moment the only ones in
oxford are at the service center and
they're up on the
veranda and the town hall and they're on
the marina as well so
um the really high use areas um
such as the bakeries and the shops that
don't have any
bike um facilities at the moment so i
think it's kind of
one help to tidy up on a sunday when
there are bikes through and everywhere
um and also enough people to go on and
have somewhere to tie them up and be
have a peace of mind that they're not
going
next um while they're in in one of the
shops and in terms of the seat
um i agree with the comments really made
i think it's
an asset to the to the township um
i don't think there's a lot of seating
along that main street at the moment so
i think it's a
yeah a really um really great addition
to the main street
[Applause]
right any anymore
all right laura doesn't pay for that
motions
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's quite a simple report in terms of
it's
carrying on from the information you
will be familiar with around mandeville
and the corner development that's gone
on there in the car park
that's been provided um
parking area um and there's a request
for
a plan to be provided to the board um
showing where
the bit more of the immunity seating
would go in the wider
space of that corner reserve and so
tori's drawn there
um identified where she would propose
the two
picnic tables which have been kindly
donated by the
residents association would be best
located
and we've spoken with james ensor
who is i guess leading the charger on
these
um he's indicated that the residence
association is
happy to i guess go about organizing the
installation of
the concrete pads for the tables to sit
on but
they appreciate the cost of the
materials so the
cement and things if the board was able
to
meet those costs and he's estimated that
that
would be around 500 um and
taking into account you have allocated
money from the general landscaping
for the seat i can't say this still is
budget available to cover that
should you wish to from your
general landscaping budget um
and i have spoken to james around the
health and safety
um i guess requirements on council in
terms of making sure that work is done
by
someone
read and happy to answer your questions
are the medieval residents association
aware of the proposed
sites
i'm not familiar with it in deep with
the communication
tories had with them but i believe that
is the case
i didn't when i was talking to james um
if i
spoke through he had a couple questions
around making sure the trees were
so the seats weren't a spot where they
would get some shade
and things like that so we spoke through
that and he seemed quite happy with the
location so i can't
about three days before the agenda
closed for granted
um and so just to clarify so the 500
indicated cost of materials is for
concrete
and then the tables are donated
that's my understanding i'm just coming
across
just a question about the report and
point 1.2 it mentions that these tables
to be included in the development plan
for the reserve which had previously
been approved by the board i don't think
we have approved a development plan have
we this is the first time i've
actually seen this this plan of
what's been tabled to my knowledge um
and probably going on from that have the
residents associate or were the
residents association
consulted with before that car parking
area was developed
i'm not entirely sure around the world
but i think that there might be more
meaning in terms of the
proposal for accepting the tables into
that reserve
was so not the serious development plan
of how they arranged the more that
the board was in favor of accepting the
tables
association this is the first time i've
seen this
[Music]
association and this is the first time
that i've seen anything to do with the
research
i was just going to say if the board
chooses to
um you could add a recommendation around
um circulating it to the mandible
residence association
for comment but yeah sorry i
comment in
just as a question that if this goes
back to the residence
association then it's actually going to
hold
up putting the picnic tables in which
has been
probably almost a year since they were
first
measured that they go on so that's
something out of the club the community
report needs to consider
under one point two
there's final proposal made by the
mental risk association
so this request for these two seats in
that location
has come from the mra initiated by them
that's the question i'm asking is if
there are internal policies of who's
telling who's really not our interest
but if the mra has said we want this in
general because they're mma
then if that's the official line from
them
then surely our job is purely just to
approve the funding
if that's where they want the seat's
going it's my only comment on it
i think the confusion there is
so the proposal from the resident
association
to provide the tables
has come from them but the actual
locations
where they would be sighted has been
recommended by tory stapleford whose
landscape architecture now
green space department so i believe
ray's
more asking around the sighting of
that the association haven't necessarily
seen exactly where they would be cited
as opposed to
them understanding that the tables are
coming from them is that correct
my my thoughts around this are that we
have consulted with the mandeville
community
just prior to christmas and
this plan had been consulted upon as far
as
the parking and the pathway and
where parking was going to be etc so
i believe that the concept roughly for
for this reserve has already been
consulted upon
and at that time over a year ago these
tables had been
donated by james that photo in your
report is actually my photo that i took
and gave you a year ago
so um
whose was this toys
idea as to where these should go based
on feedback from james
um i i think likely the other way around
in terms of
from her experience as a landscape
architect
the best sites she believed they would
be in
and then that's been communicated back
to james who's
agreed that they're good spots
right the
car backing is probably more than double
the capacity
for the area um i thought that the oil
spaces the old woods were
a little bit narrow after i saw the
volatiles and
in place never seen a plan before it
actually happened
but going down there on saturday when
when it was virtually full
last weekend uh there seemed to be
plenty of room even for the big
four-wheel drive so
i think that's been a fantastic um
addition
to the overall concept um
just one question about that uh it was
going to be sealed or
chipped is that still happening
i don't believe there was any budget
allocated to
chipping or sealing it as far as my
understanding from
cloud for green space manager
um the original plan for that due to the
type of soil and whatnot that is in this
place
being quite stony um it was never meant
to be a formalized sealed
car park it was always just going to be
um
if anything a little bit of chip if
necessary but because that is
quite light sturdy ground it was always
just meant to be
left in the way that it is now because
it is
more in keeping with the rural area and
and our budget
just one last question um there was talk
earlier
of um landscaping this particular area
is that still in the budget
rather than just having car parks in a
couple of um
tables uh it is very close to tram road
there is just a ah a farm fence that's
been put there which
will probably stop children running out
there
but is there any type of screening
proposed and
and the trees that are there that are
that are scraggly
uh is there anything in this year's
budget for those to be
either trimmed or removed
currently uh in terms of what's planned
as a business with a
what's on that development plan you've
got to hit it
in front of you um that can like you say
can be altered or
screened planting added into
that plan should the board wish but they
would
require funding allocation because
there's no
allocated funding towards that and my
understanding is
that we've got no planting
budgets due to the covert effects of
government
and things and so
if the board wants to do that there
could be a potential
project for your general landscaping
budget you don't have
probably enough money to at this moment
but you will get likely an allocation
next year
um in terms of the trees my
understanding
is that we've had
arborists out there and making
sure the trees are safe and that that
work has been done
short of that i don't think there's any
current plan to be chopping any more out
or
doing
[Applause]
right
i would like to move that we accept the
recommendation
a through d that
we install the two picnic tables
as per recommendations i think that
you know this is a long time in coming
these these tables have been sitting at
the platform
waiting for um to
you know start waiting for something for
about a year now
i know
see sarah if there is everything on so
in a second
great i think it's a great thing also
we're looking forward to some more in
the future some money
[Applause]
i just talked about the comment it's
actually good to see community-led
projects that
aren't relying on council to hold their
hand and do everything for them
and it's great to see that the manual
residents association have sort of
worked around the health and safety
rules so that they can actually do this
themselves
i think it's a great initiative
thank you
[Applause]
is
we have two applications for
discretionary
funding
[Applause]
before we get underway with that my son
goes to a book school so
would that constitute
of interest my grandson goes
okay anybody
okay
[Applause]
please i'll move
um probably not separately i'll move
that we approve 500
towards the my mercury golf club towards
the cost of their
replacing their greens now
and everyone can load up yeah
yes
i'm heavily supported as long as they
understand that they've got a time frame
i'm always the loser
because there is still a big funding gap
in that from other major organizations
so as long as they're aware that
if they've run out of time with us and
we need to reapply them
probably on that i think they're
actually a pretty proactive club so i
have full confidence that they will do
it if they said that they can do it i'm
yeah i'm fully supportive that they can
do it i think in the past they've done a
wonderful job the grounds are
really well maintained and i think in
the past when they've
proposed projects such as the water
filtration system in the past
and they've been really proactive in
their fundraising so i
think definitely think they'll be able
to make that fundraising target
any further yeah um
[Music]
at all
okay now we need someone to
do a motion for you know school
surely i would like to move that we
approve a grant for 488.43 to the over
i hope your school towards the cost of
purchasing new high jump
equipment i'll i'll second it
okay any further discussion
can we get more than what they actually
say or not
yes keep your hand down
all right the secular smith
was in favor of emotion i know
because we make no sense
the motion has been cut emotions passed
thank you because they've got
holes all over their budgets right now
and they have used this equipment my
kids have been there for 14 years
and it's always been the same equipment
and it's never been any good and it's
getting worse
and it's in desperate need of
replacement so
thank you very much for those of the
support of this
i thought i thought that primary school
didn't go for 14 years
my children
[Applause]
i propose that we're gonna have a
meeting and at the workshop
and um
[Applause]
yes
so before we start is this the same as
the one that we were emailed out
yes okay because it was yeah it was a
couple of days difference i thought it
might have been updated
thank you um the council
earlier this week adopted the um
temperature strategy and
this is the next part so the policy
is what guides the day-to-day operation
of the cemeteries
whereas the strategy was more for future
planning making sure that
the council had enough land in the
series
for cemeteries so it's
the rules of operating the symmetry plus
um also to protect the public health and
the environment
so this is an early draft of the
cemetery policy
and that's going to give the boards the
opportunity to
contribute to the content of the policy
before it goes out for public
consultation
early in the new year
there are a couple of points that
lindley
about recognition of religious
cultural requirements and what this
caused in the policy is suggesting that
if there are
a particular religious or cultural group
that would
land set aside for their group
then the council would facilitate that
happening
it's not something that happens at the
moment the old
um early part of where you're launching
did have
religious denominations in it but
it was a little bit problematic because
it's very hard at the start to divvy up
how much space each of this nomination
would require so we found that there's
some use of this space and approached
into others and
others still have space available so um
in the rest of the council symmetries
and in the new part of the angular
symmetry we're not doing that
but there could be a time when a
cultural religious group that asks for
land to be set aside
and this is allowing for that to happen
the other new clause
is clause 12 and that's regarding
the other organizations
leading cemeteries to the council
so if there's a cemetery that's managed
by a church or a trust
it's outlining some
i guess guidelines or rules about the
council taking over those cemeteries
when that organisation is unable to
manage them
and in the review of the burial and
cremations act which is before
parliament was still before parliament
obviously now they've
stopped for the election but that
it's a brief summary of obviously
everybody's
hair reading this i'm happy to
write down your comments and answer
questions
really good um with regard to the
memorial seats they differ
that if anyone wants them um just
regarding
uh if will it will likely be allowed to
get plaques on them
and if so who would be responsible for
those
you know are we brass plug
so generally the seat would be donated
by
a family and um and they would
meet the cost of that
would they be allowed to have memorial
parks on them
yes it would be a standard yeah a small
standard
plaque
yeah um i'm just wondering
at this stage there's no um pizza
in cemeteries
or
[Applause]
and this is a comfort thing for that
person to go i find it quite
it doesn't sit well with me being not
allowed to take and happy yeah and i
don't know if i would be
alone with that i know maybe
some people have issues with
[Music]
pretty much everything
try to limit the amount of memorabilia
in the symmetries and i've got a good
reminder of the reason why
that's the case when i visited the
regular cemetery
before work on monday and there were
plastic
flowers and bits and pieces all over the
lawn
because they've been strong with this
the previous night
and the lady from delta was just going
around with this huge
plastic bag um where something was
beside a grave she was putting it back
where it wasn't
and she was just putting them in the
plastic bag and
taking them away so i guess we're trying
to limit
limit it to things that are small and
are liable to stay with output
but we do concede that over the last
i'd say five to ten years there has been
more
stuff left at grades and
i'm expecting that that will change and
the public consultation
[Music]
i guess the important things are that we
eliminate stuff that can be broken
um solar lights people leave and
that they attract people at night so
um i'm expecting that will widen
what people can leave but the important
things are
that there's things that will remain at
the greatest site if there's a
wind or they don't cause offence to
anybody else
and that they are within the
area of that grave and they're not
encroaching onto others
because that does cause upset to some
people
policy
um
thank you just in class 11.1 on cemetery
maintenance
um there's a sentence in here that says
council may remove any trees shrubs or
other vegetation that have been planted
on a burial site or within the cemetery
without
council's written consent now was that
does that read correctly is it is it
meant to say
without the um
family's consent or is it meaning
without asking
members if somebody has planted
something without the consent of the
council
the council could remove it
[Applause]
because we couldn't we wouldn't be
coming to council with
every time that happened i was thinking
that being us or was that just a typo
when it was meant to mean the family's
written consent or
okay
generally if we were asked if somebody
could plan
something we would decline it at the
outset
but sometimes things just pop up
in that case would you actually if there
was you know like a rice bush planted
would you be asking to tell the family
that you'll be removing it
because i'm quite sure that if they went
it'll go long and kind of missing
it'd be questions asked yeah we would we
would make every attempt
to to contact people if it was a rose
bush
and there were ashes gardens then we
would
offer to move it
into the ashes gardens but
they do get problematic in the
in the main cemetery area particularly
when
they're okay for a while when they're
being looked after but then they
um yeah they tend to get at that unruly
end
and grow over other another growth
[Music]
actually put look at them and we put a
hole to that
generally we depends when we become
aware of it
and um often we just give it a little
bit of time
but eventually you come to the point
where the grass needs to be reinstated
so
then we would contact the family and um
and ask them to remove it or if they
didn't want to remove it then then we
would
answer any questions comments
through this process because it's
already been in another
process yeah yes that's it's already
covered off in another
council document if you like in the dog
controlled by law and there's also
adult policy underneath that bible and
the policies sort of says things like
you can't have dogs near
these playground areas and that's the
thing and i've got it
pretty strong in my mind that you can't
have in cemeteries either in their
policy
i think with those you need to be
careful because some people love them
others don't and can be intimidated by
them
so if there's an exuberant dog running
around
then um you know it could
offend or upset some people
the other thing is if the dog did fell
on a
grave and the owner wasn't aware of them
able to clean it up then
they would certainly be upsetting for um
you know for somebody who
visited the cemetery and found it so
um i mean i'm a
i'm a dog owner as well um i like to
think i
i'll clean up after them and look after
them but
that's not always the case
i'm assuming you don't want it that's
wrong but you're talking about dogs
being buried with their own
[Music]
you know
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's
what you have for me
[Applause]
just on that though is it not better to
manage it by
not saying anything because the
overwhelming majority of people that
would bring
dogs into a cemetery if they were
allowed
are probably people who don't have loved
ones buried there
but i'm sure that if you had a very well
behaved pocket pooch in your arms that
you brought to go see their master's
grave i don't think
um you know if it wasn't encouraged and
officially sanctioned
like i don't think anybody would really
give you too much hassle without me
without going down there with a lot of
making it official that you know
it's probably best to be silent on that
issue
and um rather than encourage it
kind of like mandeville parking before
it was sanctioned
and the difficulty is that if you are
silent on it
and there is a nuisance it's been
quite difficult to um
deal with that owner um we're better i
think to be out front
and make that known and if somebody
if somebody takes the dog into to visit
and it doesn't cause any problems and we
don't know about it
we're not going to be looking looking
for that but i i do think we need to
make rules like that now and to
[Applause]
thank you
meeting
right there is no correspondence
and the chairperson's report they're
doing performance and we knew that
they've been
received
[Applause]
thank
right so sunday the last sunday being
the 4th of october i helped out with the
garage sale trail in oxford handing out
maps um
pretty busy morning really um probably
gave out
well onto the hundreds of maps and
really was only one
grumpy person a good complainant um
uh so no it was a good morning yeah yeah
probably only downside was it was a bit
windy
um but yeah the town was buzzing all
sunday so it was good to see
um i attended the walking cycling
strategy as
a member from oxford promotions um
sarah also attended them i was a bit
disappointed to see that the focus was
just on cycleways it wasn't actually
really a walking cycling strategy it was
more just a cycleway strategy
um and it would have been good to if
we're going to have an overarching plan
to have one that sort of
links together and um has a bit of
cohesion around the walking and the
cycling routes
um but i think that's pretty much over
over now um
i attended the all boards meeting um
last week whenever that was
um as well as the points were at all
as well as the points road water scheme
meeting
um the
meeting it had a good outcome in the end
but i think it was
a pretty muddled way to get there i
think that it could have been
um the presentation could have been a
wee bit more
uh concise um and actually given a
more it was a bit confusing for the
first half i i felt personally and i
sort of knew what was going on and i
could see why there was a little
confusion around the room um but and
then we got to the
result we wanted the result that was
good for the community so it was good
but
um also she attended an all chat in all
board chairs meeting with deputy chairs
in the mirror
um probably the main thing that was
talked about there was the long-term
plan
um and just the direction that we're
probably looking at heading out over the
next um six months
and the fact that the ball was a bit of
a feeling from all the board chairs
it would be good to have a workshop this
side of christmas
around the sort of workout priorities
and stuff going
into that process so when we do come to
make a submission
um we sort of know what we're talking
about
um but all in all i thought it was a
that was a good meeting it was also
the idea of a caricature before or board
meetings was
raised um and that's something that this
board i think
should work shop on and doug mentioned
in his chairperson's report
um but yeah i think it would be
something a good thing for the board to
sit down and have a bit of a
conversation about in a workshop setting
um and then the only other thing i've
got is the oxford community trusts agm
is on the 13th of october which is
coming up
it's at the amp rooms of the oxford town
hall so
anyone's welcome to attend if they would
like
let's hear it um
meeting um from
that meeting we went ahead and put some
ideas
down on a network map
christmas appointed in the
outlook for this microwave network it's
um
completely urban focus there's no focus
on rural areas at all
i suggested that
we look at creating cycle ways
connecting homes to schools
and homes to other community areas um
within our rural areas um and the point
was that the funding is driven for urban
areas
and around the population that serves we
had to put in our annual plan to council
about
um these particular cycleways more
points for our rural areas
their response was there is a cyclewaste
network
being a group being created that will
cover that
so that's another correct response
because because like always people are
saying no
it's not what um their funding is going
to be used for
so that leaves our rural areas um
basically
out of um of this
this initiative which i find very
disappointing so
um yeah that
yeah i keep fighting out
[Music]
and they are
going to look at some minor works
at this stage and it may need adhere
the behavior that's going on and
increases safety for the area
so i'm hoping that um they will have a
look into that and they will get back to
us
as to what they are proposing before
they go ahead and do anything
um and yesterday six october was
a wag meeting um there's
quite a large focus on mental health
services at the moment
and ensuring that there's enough of them
to meet the needs
and a new initiative started up um
called his hip and coaches and started
certain doctors surgeries and run your
inquiry and then it's hoping to extend
out when
so you can go to your doctor and if you
have many mental health issues and there
is someone there that can
work with you um more looking at
short-term
mental health issues and also
um council community team i'm
looking at making services that are
available
a bit more user orientated so
to cover for people that may be looking
for
through being services or help in any
other way that don't usually
fit the usual customer
um so people that are in a situation
that may not usually be in the situation
because of
um maybe their business is not doing so
well or
whatever that usually would have been
services and make it so that they can
don't have to go to a person to be able
to access it they can
access it themselves i'd be a bit more
dish discreet i suppose
about it so i think that's a really
great idea um
yeah they've been working really hard on
lots of good
things recovery
right right
uh 10th of september i went to the otago
a hoka
drainage advisory group and meeting in
chi point
various uh issues were discussed
uh one that was uh
i said okay no it's fine no
um one one one topic of interest was
was the idea of wetlands and wetlands in
the ohoka area
and that there are pockets of calcium
lens
and that they they could well be
utilized as natural wetland
areas to help improve water quality and
control flooding but there were some
negative comments about this
and the ability to be able to maintain
these
waterways if they were indeed to become
wetlands
investigations are ongoing for proper
places for riparian plantings adjacent
to the waterways to assist with the
maintenance of the drains and water
races throughout
the ohio area and also
[Music]
questions were again asked about the
flood litigation
uh what what is the council doing in
swans and mendel
as regards to flood litigation um the
answer was something like that
investigations were continuing this
financial year
but any construction of land works is
not likely to occur
in the next three years
15th of september there was a a natural
disaster workshop
in rangiora where um
the natural disasters
list of liquefaction ejector flooding
earthquake fault lines
coastal erosion and tsunami which would
well affect
um resource consent applications and
building consent
applications and these natural disaster
maps
as we know now are all being updated on
the on the website
yeah the other interesting thing was
that we were divided into groups
and there were different scenarios that
were played out in these groups
and they vary from
he would deal with a an ordinary old um
small shed being built in the middle of
a rural farm
uh how that right the way through to how
we would consider
uh a nuclear power station being
proposed in the middle of rangiora
uh quite interesting how people
[Music]
decided on how they how the different
planners
should approach the different scenarios
and then that evening there was an
awkward meeting in rangiora an update on
the three waters
status and then i had a discussion
out of west newton with the oaks reserve
group just regarding the community board
landscaping grant of five thousand
dollars that we had
uh given to them just explained that uh
there was a time limit on that
and that uh they're putting it out to
the community for
more general discussion the 22nd
september the mandeville sports club
have their agm
and mandible important points to come
out of that is the new toilet block
that the council of funding construction
is about to start there
many positive comments about the new
caterer
and news that the strategic plan was
almost
finalized 24th of september
and was a public meeting river points
rope with the supply in oxford
and generally the residents seem to be
in favor of the council's new plan
whereby the residents of points work
will join the westminster
scheme 28th of september
there's a more boards meeting in kayak
where i won't go into
too much detail because i think most
people were there
and on the yesterday i attended a great
power meeting
in rangiora points to come out of that
is that the
changes to to the home care um
were again discussed but that um
it was difficult meeting with the cd hp
because there was so many resignations
of
important staff and it was very
difficult to get actual
um decisions on
exactly what's what is going to be
happening with
gear for the for the elderly and note
that there is like here now there's an
ophthalmologist in rangiora
but the cancer infusion treatment is
only available in ambly or
kaiakoi and not in running
or oxford but at least it is out here
now
cycleways came up for discussion and
many asked the question
uh we are they able to use their
mobility scooters on the
um on the proposed cycleways and the
existing cycleways
and what about for people who just want
to walk
um grey power presenting a position to
the government will be the
aged and disabled who are not having
access to
i.t when
it's so important now that for
everything from
banking through to retailing
and it's it's becoming a real
issue for some of the elderly and it was
noted that probably in 20 years climate
might be an issue because
everybody reaching that particular age
will be
relatively confident in it
men's sheds provided a
pamphlet on budget coffins
which was pretty well received
fine confidence at a very reasonable
rate
and we had a guest speaker from the fire
risk
management in the home which was
very informative in that anyone over the
age of
60 is able to have the
smoke detectors checked the home and
that found policy can be replaced free
of charge
so i think a lot of the members there
were going to be taking advantage of
that another speaker talked on
parkinson's
something like about 3 000
cantabrians suffer from this particular
disease all the way through to
from 20 year olds to very very elderly
and it seems that
it is able to be managed really well now
with uh drugs
that one thing i didn't i didn't realize
is that you can't die from parkinson's
but you can die with parkinson's and
it's um
it's uh excuse me
a debilitating um disease that we all
know
um but there are a lot of things that
can be done to improve that
the life of um sufferers
that's what i have um i had a number of
questions
that i was going to to last three
reports but is this a
relevant time it's here or should i
wait for another time and do it and
remember
yeah yeah yeah so number four later
surely
on the episode attended the
access group meeting there was a
powerpoint presentation done by
karina who's the lady from the low
vision foundation
and it was about issues that people
are finding in shopping centres
there is an awful lot that the disabled
and the local
low-vision people actually do come
across
and then they went out for an exercise
in kaiapoi but i didn't participate in
that
i was too frightened too i did
i did attend the uh points road water um
skid meeting and yes that would have
been nice if the council had sort of
said what they were really going to do
at the very beginning which would have
saved a lot of time
um on the 28th of september there was a
community
combined community board and those
people that were there would've heard
my comments about the visitor strategy
i am concerned that enc
is going to be very involved with that
even though
it has been told to me that
that it's going to be driven by the
waimakariri district council
out of the 28 objectives
the enc are going to be responsible for
20 of them
and i have been involved since the early
1990s with promotion of the ymca
the oxford promotions and really
we need to promote our district and i
don't believe
unless they change their system it's not
going to happen
indeed and it was alluded to that they
won't change
their website the way they do it
um you have to be a business partner
which i would have been like from
day one till last year
you have to pay again so like
oxford has two food places to eat at on
there
the farmers market and cruisy days they
have four
activities and one is the town hall i
mean
i don't know how we can actually get
our district promoted better
um so maybe it's something
we all we all need to look at because
the council
are really giving the promotion at
getting
back to eating scene visit
so it does need to be something done
and i i don't really know what
nestle i've got
[Applause]
um it seemed to be that during the month
and one week i took off on the holiday
everyone decided to have their meetings
their week so um
but i obviously when else i attended the
points wrote all the meetings
um the opportunity for me of the west
head and submittal group
is to try and find some common ground
with my group
that we can put to the table the points
of our group if they wish
to negotiate get on the scheme so
i think great progress we've made with
the council government funding
it's going to be quite a bit of work
still to do to actually agree on the
final
outcomes of doing the two schemes and
obviously when that comes aboard this
board i will step back because i mean
i'm a
chair of the scheme and also a rate
payer under the woodsman
i attended a meeting on half of the
board i was blown away that one business
actually sent a staffing
i think which is great because we're
still four
board members there and a few other
people but
i'm surprised for the lack of business
people that come to those meetings
the opec optical promotions actually
[Music]
[Applause]
would be very positive feedback at the
meeting and i think the entire agn took
31 minutes to get through which is
pretty good
um i've talked with the west end all
share regarding my own reserve i
couldn't go so
thank you to ray for advertising for me
for that meeting i will catch up with
the garden club
and the school um also to coordinate the
left
and that same week was an oxford rural
branch meeting and thank you for doug
with deputizing for me on that one and
the last thing i had was an email from
ray payer um who had
a building on the property next door put
up
counsellors signed off on drainage
consent
there was an issue with drainage um
she was getting a little bit um
annoyed at progress she reached out to
me purely because she knows me through
equestrian circles um and through
talking with getting advice um
and how we should handle it council
staff have since
been i think gone out to see the right
player and this
has identified there's been an issue
with the drainage
design and they're going to arrange
contractors to come in and try and
rectify
it's a nice little win for the rapper
[Music]
can i just comment on mark's comment
regarding officer promotions
in the businesses the retail businesses
haven't
attended but i also know that the
renewal
business the network runs no very very
few
retailers go they are the big businesses
um and service providers
you know like the electrician or
something like that so
i don't know whether it's something that
retailers don't want to do busy
mentioned that the waimakariri district
council
has lost a very valuable um
person um
yolanda simon very sad indeed
54 years of age to cancer so
it's just ghastly um
we're all very thoughtful for all the
staff
that they um go through this brief at
the moment
[Applause]
unfortunately i couldn't go
to the auburn's meeting nor could i go
to other things that
i had because i had vertigo
and i wasn't really fit to be doing
anything
and i missed out on the um because i
chair the project group for
the indoor court facility so i missed
out on the
roof shout but i just got to
see this around for you to have a look
at just how the stadiums
are producing and growing and now so
that's
the other thing i want to bring you up
to
is that there's going to be a one-stop
shop event
for rural waste recycling and the
waimakariri district council on monday
the 2nd of november
it will be in oxford and
so the farmers do have to register
online there so i'll park that past that
round there
the other thing that i just quickly need
to
say to you about and from my community
recreation head on here
that on tomorrow thursday
in the libraries the children are having
a popularity mystery trail this is
for regular
and they've got to go around and
find all different types of jungle
animals so
they'll be really exciting for them to
enjoy
the library i will say the library is
absolutely
buzzing and it keeps such a delight to
see
indeed it's really the aquatics facility
also
as as buzzing with
new things that are happening in the
area and
there's a new inflatable and ring europe
and whitehall gets a big thumbs up on
his kids jokes or holiday time
so there's lots of little things that
are happening that they're really
giving the children a pretty good
problem doing things together
the other thing that i just like to
briefly bring up because i am on the age
friendly
group and um
just i i just feel that
looking at what the council has put
together for
staying socially connected i'm afraid
there's
quite a lot of stuff um in our rural
towns that are just not even being put
onto here so
i just think i need and i think this is
already going out so we need to address
this
and go through because there's
really important that um you know for
people who can't have a cup of tea
and things like that and us and we need
to be where they
become the socially uh
but with cabin fever and things like
they can come in and have a cup of tea
and get to save her to people and become
become more
part of our community it's really
important
because the elderly will hide away
because it's easier that way
[Music]
last thing i'd like to say i really
would like to congratulate
the officer rural dry drainage advisory
group
they're a very proactive group they
are very well connected with their
with the area and they are
pretty frugal and
thank you for that great update wendy
yeah i suppose a lot of the things that
i'm talking about probably crossed over
um on the 9th of september
we had the tiatiawa working group
meeting and
what that is when we're talking about
mapping rivers and things
and planting buttons that kind of goes
hand in hand with that
at the moment they're mapping the camera
stream works
for a project at present but they'll
hope to roll that out to other
[Applause]
rivers and streams later on um
but yeah kind of start somewhere um the
prevention
of alcohol and drug power steering group
also met and debriefed after the pad
buffet tour but we
welcomed grant harris who has just
wonderfully fallen in our lap he is
um he works with the city mission for
um as a rehab counselor and
he'll be a really great asset for us to
have in the district with his
knowledge and experience
on the 10th of september i had the
privilege of judging the north
canterbury primary school's debating
semi-finals
which were between a hookah one and a
hoka two
and laubern and ashgrove and um there's
four
four schools um put on really awesome
performances it was really quite
cool to watch and then i went to the
october
drainage advisory group meeting which is
in the chairman's report and has been
discussed by ray so i'll leave that
there
on the 11th of september was the greater
christchurch partnership meeting
i don't know who here has seen anything
about
the engagement or survey about what you
would like
to like the greater christchurch
area um great pressures 2050 to
look like has anyone seen that because
you now they there's a survey that's not
live as of the 5th of october it runs to
the 8th of november
please go have a look um it's on
www.greaterchristchurch.org.nz
um it's it's really important um
planning document for them to consult
with people and see what they think
um you know if they're heading the right
direction
with the greater christchurch which of
course
that encompasses solar and why micro
duty as well as crashes city
and just what we want the city to you
know and the greater pressure to look
like
um anyhow go have a look at that
um ray mentioned that there was on the
15th of september
a district planning regulation briefing
on natural hazards that was quite a cool
exercise um yeah it was quite
fascinating to see people's appetite for
risk with regard to
natural hazards and that is going to be
some really important work
that will go into how we draw out the
district plan with what's
permitted not permitted what needs
consents etc and so on
so that's quite a cool
exercise um
the utility inverting has
and it cancel later we have in fact
as per recommendation by this board um
closed
the stock water race at siena place
which we have all talked about um that
just
got the final pick of approval yesterday
um
they are also undertaking an opaque
water safety plan which
although not legally required for
supplies under 500 households
is going to be undertaken anyway because
it's just good practice so
um so that's underway i also went to the
all boards briefing
and you guys are all there so
um on the 17th of september i met with
dave taylor from
landcare glenn michael from bio health
the
fascinating gentleman regarding a
locally produced product
that can sustainably and more cost
effectively increase productivity of
soils which could be of use to local
farmers lifestyles
and also the council for lands for
council landing reserves
so that should be that might be
interesting
to look into and
then i'll skip over all of that um
the 23rd of september we that wendy and
i
and the mayor and some of our staff
and nzta staff met with tina dudley
whose daughter was recently in a car
accident at the tram road motorway
off-ramp just to just to discuss and
explore options for
improving the safety of that at that
intersection
so i think that was quite a productive
you know meeting it at the time the
speed limit where that happened would
have been 50 kilometers an hour
um but it still happened because the
the car that pulled out in front of the
person coming down tram road
couldn't see they were in a car a low
vehicle and
there was really no place to go so it
did cause some some harm
and they really you know that's a
terrible intersection and it has been
forever
and um fingers crossed they're finally
gonna be able to maybe do
something about that but you know that's
in the works at the moment
um on that same day there was
the global welfare committee roundup
which is
um a whole group of
waimakari's social services providers
that have been meeting since lockdown
just to share information and resources
about community needs
but as things seem to settle down
for now the meetings have been
discontinued the regulations have
discontinued until further notice if
needed
yesterday was a council meeting which
i probably discussed
all the exciting things in that and
last thing for me on the 15th of october
at long last mark
we are finally going to have the first
meeting in the elected members
sustainability steering group hallelujah
well um yes i have been appointed
as an observer to the christchurch
city um climate change and climate
change coastal
working group and what that
why i've been appointed and what that
really means as an observer is that i
hold the climate change and
sustainability portfolio
and whilst i'm i don't have voting
rights or anything like that we all
share the same coastline
you know an earth earthquake or tsunami
or
or climate change doesn't go that's
christ your city and that parts
so it's quite awkward to be able to work
with with
our partners on the other side of the
river mouth so
i missed anything else there's been an
awful lot going on i've actually missed
an awful lot because i was away for a
week
and
did you go on the trip to the
um in the northern corridor
[Applause]
nobody can regale us with tables of how
awesome that's gonna be anyway
that is hoping to open about the 20th
of december the new corridor but i was
away and didn't get to go and look at it
darn it
so anybody else in this room would go
[Music]
um did you get an email from mike
o'connell
okay um i think he's at 130 i don't
i think yeah
[Music]
um
and oh town hall function room 1 30
p.m
is
i am very concerned about this grace
greater christchurch
thing that we're going to end up being
being like
auckland and i can't imagine what it
would be like
to be working under a council on
christchurch council
i don't think you know the idea is not
for us to invalidate into a super city
the whole idea of us working together is
so that they
don't try to make us a super city
because there are things that we do need
to work together on
and there are synergies to be had in
skills economies of scale
and also when it comes to infrastructure
and things
like transport corridors and whatnot
there are things that that it's
definitely in our best interest to work
together on
lest they do i think it might be a good
idea to
become a super city which i agree with
you would not be
um my idea of a great thing either
but please by all means you go and do
the survey
it's it's kind of unfortunate that it's
called greater christchurch maybe
in some people's eyes and they think
that we're we're all being squished into
a secret city but
um it does really encapsulate the way we
all kind of think of ourselves i mean
probably most people if you were away
from home
and you ran into somebody overseas where
are you from you probably just say
christ you're each other then
oh no or oxford because
no we're always oxford okay all right
i've attracted that statement but
three or four people talk to me um over
the last month about the pool opening
date in oxford
um it's also been on oxford chit chat i
don't know anyone seen it but um
a bit of concern from a few people
around the opening dates of that and the
fact that
i think it's like until late november um
and people were disappointed i think
it's probably something that should have
a discussion about at some point and how
we can
make that work slightly better for the
community because it's a good facility
and
it's only open for four months a year
it's sort of
not being used
with regard to enc and dropping a
visitor's
strategy um i i have asked in the past
like how many oxford businesses interact
with the ncaa
and you know because that concerns me as
well is there perhaps
something that we as a board can do to
suggest
that perhaps enc
reach a little bit further because it is
enc does work on behalf of the entire
district but it doesn't always feel that
way
i think for a lot of um businesses from
the west shall we say
would that would that be fair
um well the position is you have to be
a business partner to be on your website
and also get the information of the um
the courses they run um
i don't you know they're double dipping
in in a way
because those businesses are paying
rates
but but um this cheaply executive or
whatever it is of edc was adamant
they wouldn't change the way the website
is
done you have to pay
because they couldn't afford to to
actually put
all of the businesses who are in like
hospitality
and the retail and eating in that on it
they don't believe they could actually
do that but
we were part of a 100 pure
new zealand for a long time you know we
had
we they've got thousands of people on it
and i i don't think it's a big deal but
i just don't know about the thinking
can can we move on please
do
board funding update board discretionary
ground at 96.244
lists what we allocated tonight
general winston was funded 690
there are no media items no questions
understanding orders
no's and general business understanding
orders
so um i'm going to talk
[Applause]
yes
thank you so much
[Applause]
i'm part of the community recreation
team
and look after what we've focused on the
killer projects
and assets within our parks and reserves
community facilities um so
personally coming along tonight as
you're aware of obviously if you're
coming into the ltp um we're going to
have a session with each of the boards
just to go through at this stage what
we've got in
uh the long-term plan and to get an idea
um or focus
that the board would like to start to
consider um
sergio will be aware obviously with kobe
19 there are a number of measures
that staff took to reduce budgets for
this current financial year
parks and reserves where fort go or
joseph will go
a number of our meal budgets including
roads and car parks hardcore renewals
and our general landscape renewal
budgets which is the gardens of
um the trees is that basically headed
back in an exponential year
um it was always continued only before
one year as a cost-saving measure
we've obviously still got focus on
keeping the rates down
as part of this ltp and at this stage
we've not included any large projects
for that um within parts and reserves
we've also
focused on renewing and maintaining our
existing basic network
um so at this stage the three projects
that i've got
the budget from last ltp uh the kerfur
street reserve
it's carried in 2122 financial a year
it's proposed to push this out one year
we've got eastern domain development and
w78
tourism infrastructure fun
funding um
um the current project we've got was
financially just for reference we've
also got a manual toilet which has been
spoken about tonight
um and they're also putting a flag track
system across the district which doesn't
include big
so if you take any flags or you know um
that board may have around chemical
projects called the ltp
[Applause]
street services so it's the free trade
system for the street flavors
and the christmas please that we've put
up
it just saves um it's getting a cheery
quick remember
[Laughter]
christchurch city council just have a
man that drives along at night and goes
up in a bucket and changes them
um why can't we do that it just seems
like he was
i quite often do nights in the center of
christchurch and he'll just drive along
put a coat put some cones out around
them they're gone in 10 minutes and it's
done um it just seems like such a simple
system when we make it such a plava to
be honest
i think that's the point of going with
the flag track system
um that we can have someone just on the
ground come along and put them up
yep this is just the man of a cherry
picker guy he's got a truck he just
drives along goes up james it comes down
he's done
um i just don't know why that's not an
option out here
uh so this is the actual rail system
because she's very good
and hopefully that um
tourism
[Applause]
um so for the long term plans are
you looking for it's this is to get a
bit of an idea from the board
there is a concern that maybe
parks and receivers of community
facilities that we need to put a project
out
as part of tpp is
so we'll probably have we'll probably
have a couple of workshops
i think that's what we're looking at
doing having one this side of christmas
and sort of look at more
i like ideas sort of things and then
sort of come back after christmas
and sort of get more sort of look at the
actual
wording of the projects we're looking at
doing so it's
this is probably more just at the very
start of things if
i'm yeah sort of getting things so
probably not necessarily looking for
ideas more directions tonight isn't it
yeah
um
figures are looking with the code the
trunk balance cable projects watching
out one year
um beastie isn't playing in 2028
and the resources
we also do have a number of other
so what are you planning on doing on the
kawaii street
reserves because i thought um
had
um
i think it's probably quite an important
one because for people that don't know
it there's a big role of
like a macrocarpa hedge isn't there
surely and then there's a row of
redwoods behind it so it's actually
really dark most of uh it's dark all day
during winter um
and it's quite a long footpath like it's
probably
500 meters
yeah i think it's probably something we
should be advocating for and um
the type of thing that i think would be
really beneficial if before anything got
set in stone would be
go to the schools and say hey look give
us some ideas
what do you guys want to see in your
community and they would be
thrilled to have the chance to
um i mean schools can even put it in as
one of their
one of their term um projects where they
where the kids have to come up with
different designs and be part of the
process
and this is exactly the type of relation
that i'm
kind of hoping to
build with and to encourage
better relations with council
and communities through that revenue so
i think that this would be a perfect
um chance to do that i'm really happy to
work alongside you guys if you want to
um what to go to do anything like that
to work with schools in our ward
i guess because i'm new i don't really
know the time frames and things but if i
had enough
warning as to when these things were
coming up in the time frame that i can
get to the schools and say hey look this
is coming up
if you've got a chance put it in your
curriculum
or put it in or do it as a web project
and
and send the ideas to the
about the board going through their
projects that they would like to perform
as part of the course
[Music]
think i'm wanting to do it do a
bmx track at school and i just think
that
that might be something that
they could receive some help with
because kids can go
[Applause]
we will set up a formal workshop to
cover all this stuff later
yeah i just don't want to be too late
because school is going to end up having
they're going to need a
you know a good term i think that's
where the idea of having two this time
came from because in the past we've
tried to do it one
and it's sort of just everyone sort of
tried to chuck as much stuff on there as
possible and just
sort of make a bit of a random list
whereas it's good to have a bit of time
to go around these groups and if we have
ideas canvas them with them and see if
they're actually good ideas
because um that's right well the best
people that know their own community
they're the people that live in them
yeah okay so
just a good question what weeks
late and got a response that you
presented
to the council
long-term plan now so when is the
cut-off to get this done
in terms of the awesomeness of this
submission to the long-term plan so
they're probably submitting it to get it
into the draft plan
whereas we can submit on the draft plan
if you know um
um
so would that match would that then be
around about the time
where say schools would make a
submission to a lot too times
submissions so that's when this would be
appropriate for a school
yeah so it wouldn't
hurt though if i started getting in
contact with these schools and just
saying hey look this is going to be
coming up
if you do want to put it in because turn
forwards are really starting so we're
going to be the beginning of the team
absolutely that's fine it's exactly the
same way that ryan and his crew
are working on their draft right
everyone's sort of trying to get it done
before christmas because yeah
council's going to be considering a
two-to-day third period
yeah she needs to be on council
public land not school school or
anything yes
yes i understand that and that's also
why i wanted to meet with
i don't think it was your thing's grunt
about where are all these reserves and
stuff in our district
so where are they in there
well um
if we're looking at that though look at
the parcels of land that aren't actually
like unused recreational reserves as
well though
the old gravel pits and stuff like that
yeah right yeah because there's one
down the corner just right next to the
woody school
like where the water tanks and things
are it's just a ghostly
like well it depends on what status is
yeah well i guess status but yeah it's
not being used
yeah that's right but it'd be nice to
know where all those little
pockets were well some of the some of
the small products we can't
because it's under the um property
management
today so and then we're going through a
process at the moment
and all these puzzles of land that
we can either acquire or move on
but we're actually looking at parklands
park
science basically areas that
or like that white road reserve where
they've done planting and those
those are the sort of things that you
look at
if you want to if you want to be part of
something and that's one in
yeah so those are the things that you
can you can look at
it's the same as clark ball with with
silver stream
they do planting down there silver
strings there
so you can look at the things that the
children might
like to be part of to embrace
the environment just like hopefully with
the hacker bush thing
there's a lot a lot of work done here
which council doesn't spend the amount
of money
so it's all part of
getting the children into thinking about
you